on a special edition of Brian Ross
investigates fasten your seatbelts
turbulence ahead airlines in an economic
freefall no one is flying pilots and
flight attendants being furloughed or
fire we're joined by the president of
the flight attendant Union for United
Airlines the skies are no longer so
friendly the crisis that hit our
industry has brought panic to everyone
Plus this week's media winners and
losers Sean Hannity your message will
never be heard whoever you people are
the White House press corps and Kelly
and Conway the editor-in-chief of
meteorite rates them all see if you
agree plus your questions about kovat 19
and the law your job your home your
rights we'd like to know what race we
have what do you suggest we do from the
law and crime Network this is a special
covered 19 edition of Brian Ross
investigates thank you for joining us
I'm Brian Ross and this is a special
edition of our program for the lawn
prime Network and for our viewers on
Facebook live and YouTube lives I'm
joined today by my colleague at law on
crime Rhonda Schwartz and Rhonda this
week we see growing concerns and a just
a cascade of bad news no fall-off said
Nikoli and the death toll from they
covered 19 illness and increasing
unemployment now 33 million people
filing for unemployment in this country
Rhonda and some industries really in
dire straits
for example nobody's flying we've seen
the empty airports despite a 25 billion
dollar federal bailout package the
famous investor Warren Buffett has
pulled all his money out of airline
stocks and says he doesn't think that
industry will survive that's a real
question for the pilots and the fund
attendants abc's nightline talked with
one pilot Dennis pager as he returned to
work for the first time here's what he
told Nightline it's been over a month
since I've been out flying just due to
all the cancellations last-minute that
have happened
we packing a little bit different than I
normally do three decades of this and
this is the first time I'm unpacking
things like mask and extra wipes and his
hand sanitizer it's captain Dennis
teachers first day on the job since
March pretty empty no doubt he's
traveling from Chicago to Miami then
landing in Houston documenting his trip
along the way a little bit harder to
find food giving us a first-hand account
of his new reality and your 30-plus
years have you ever seen anything affect
the industry quite like Kovac 19 not
this long and deep eye fluid a 911 in
the after I was in New York and that was
a shock on many levels and in horror in
the area that I don't think any of us
ever imagined this is a different shock
to us it's invisible
and it's a sentiment shared by everyone
who works for an airline I talked
earlier today with the head of the
flight attendants Union for United
Airlines ken Diaz Ken Diaz thank you so
much for joining us you were flying for
business yesterday what was it like to
be in the airports and in the air well
when I went into Chicago's O'Hare
Airport to see an empty terminal
it was actually an eerie frightening
feeling there were more passengers than
I thought there would be on the aircraft
but considering that we're only flying
10% of our flights it was good to see
for the first time more passengers than
employees for your members the flight
attendants for United this must be a
very scary time especially United now
predicting a very very slow recovery and
an entirely different airline well I
think all the communications that are
coming out from management to our
employees I mean it's a very sobering
picture that's being painted because
quite frankly no one knows when demand
is going to return
so flight attendants are
for their jobs late attendance or afraid
what the future holds and no one can
definitively answer their question
because it all depends on demand and
what the schedule will be come October
1st on the cares Act does protect
protect us until that time but until
demand comes back there's there's no way
to say how many employees will be will
be needed I mean we know it's going to
be a smaller airline industry as we
start up because all the analysts are
predicting that it's going to take not
months maybe years to get back to where
we were so hopefully that will change
but until we can get more definitive
answers from not only the government but
the the traveling public they have to
feel safe to fly we feel we're doing
everything in our power to ensure that
safety working with the airline I'm on
close with in every single day but there
is no way to predict the future not
knowing when demand for air travel will
come back to our industry and quite
frankly it's going to come back to the
domestic operation much sooner than it
comes back to the International
operation right
and for those fun attendants who are
still working still flying what's it
like for them up in the air now with
passengers everyone's wearing a mask
wearing gloves
everyone where is wearing a mask and
wearing gloves there our temperature is
checked before they enter the airport
and that's for oil airline workers so we
are trying to put every level of
protection not only for the flight
attendants that I represent but also put
the traveling public to now that they
are required to wear masks that the
comfort level of knowing that their
safety is protected of my flight
attendants and the traveling public and
it is only that confidence that's going
to bring back air travel we're still
working with the government to try to
see if if our industry could be helped
further because we think our we're a
model for every industry in this country
to keep people over off the unemployed
Alliance I mean today 33 million
Americans are out of work and and we're
essential workers and we want more
testing for flight attendants as they
are essential workers so that that can
now build the confidence level even more
but there's so much uncertainty which is
created creating the angst of the flight
attendants that I represent absolutely
and how about the real world are some of
your flight attendants had they come
down with covin 19 are they suffering
from it yes I mean unfortunately United
has had no fatalities there have been
seven flight attendants in the industry
that have passed due to Kovac 19 the
contact initially when the response was
slowed from thermal affections from from
the government direction how we stem the
tide of infection and yes we have quite
a few numbers but what I can report is
half of those flight attendants that
have been diagnosed and gone through the
illness now have tested negative and
have returned to work let me ask you
this for your men yeah I was going to
say even with voluntary furloughs to
help the airlines because this is a
balancing act I am trying to protect our
flight attendants but at the same time
working with the airline because we have
to save the airline industry and and
we're working to save United Airlines so
with that said there there are just so
many unknowns that have to be on a date
by day basis analyzed and imprudent
smart and not panicked decisions have to
be made to resurrect this industry for
the protection of the flight attendants
that the association of flight
attendants represents and right let me
ask you about your members now they're
gonna suffer real financial hardship
here what's the is there a safety net
for them so we do have contractual
provisions on how furloughs involuntary
furloughs would take place but we are in
talks with the copy
now is to make every possible voluntary
program available I have to say that I'm
so proud of our flight attendants that
for the month of April we took over a
half of the voluntary polar programs
offered at United Airlines as our
contribution to help the airline get
back on its feet
to also help other flight attendants
that weren't in a position to take time
off of work with no pay so I applaud the
flight attendants that were able to do
that and they numbered over 12,500 for
the month of April right and you know
what they've shown real courage to go
back to work to go up in the air not
knowing exactly what's going on yeah and
you have to realize these these are
ordinary you know citizens that have
families that have children there there
is an angst of not knowing their own
predicament as far as their financial
future there's an angst are they coming
in contact with the virus but I think
the precaution is that we have taken to
protect our flight attendants has shown
a level of confidence to the traveling
public so I do believe eventually that
will drive demand because people need to
feel safe to get on an airplane and and
I think that is one area with management
that we are working hand-in-hand because
as long as we can save the industry I'm
most of protecting jobs and I want jobs
for people to come back to that or the
good jobs that we've worked decades to
build
all right well ken Diaz thank you so
much for joining us today I really
appreciate it and keep in touch and to
all your members stay safe thank you
very much I appreciate the time lots of
uncertainty and ankles now as this
pandemic continues to sweep across the
country so coming up your questions
about kovat 19 and the law and then the
media's winners and losers we'll talk
with the editor in chief of media
right about who he thinks is doing well
and who is it you're watching the law
and crime trial Network
we continue now with our special covered
19 edition of our program and runner
shirts as we just heard from the flight
attendant and the pilot lots of angst in
that industry and all disease really
well we have a record 33 million
unemployed in the country this week and
it's being compared to the Great
Depression so everywhere folks have
concerns questions agony about their
paychecks their economic conditions
right so let's get right to the
questions from our viewers joined now by
Felicia Ennis of the firm Walsh or
posting and by luigi is of the Berman
Law Group thank you both for being here
there's no legal cure for angst Alicia
but what do you recommend to people who
are really worried about what's next
well Brian what I've been addressing
over the last few weeks especially is
really what's gonna happen in this next
phase you know we we've heard a lot
about reopening in certain states and in
other areas of the country and people
are nervous and rightfully so about
resuming their normal work duties and
functions and you know riding Subway's
and so forth and getting to work so you
know we've been really you know my firm
has been trying to address these issues
and helping businesses develop plans for
reopening and employees have a lot of
questions and you know we're starting to
see more answers so that's the positive
all right luigi so a question from one
of our viewers who owns a hair salon
about what she's supposed to do with
certain rulings that Jesus apparently
forced to require take a listen to
another question my name is Charlene
Peyton I live in Putnam County New York
and I've had a hair salon in Westchester
County since 2009 which was mandated to
close on March 21st due to the corona
virus pandemic that left me and many of
my colleagues without any income coming
in so I have been waiting for the
stimulus check today's may 6 then I
haven't received that and the website
says that I'm
for it and that I shouldn't call that
they will send me letter and let me know
when that check is gonna come and that's
the only information I can get on that
when I go to the regular unemployment
page it tells me that I have only
partially submerged my claim and that I
should call the claims department and
when I call the claims department it
tells me that I need to speak to someone
to finish the claim and that they'll
call me back and they never call back so
this past weekend I had some friends
come and help me empty my entire
contents of my salon into my garage
because I'm fearful that with my lease
coming up September 1st that I'm gonna
get locked out of there with all my
means to make a living in there so you
know I just don't know who to call
anymore I don't know where to get help
please tell me how I'm gonna secure my
future after this please tell me where
to turn so Luigi what would you say to
that set of questions from her well
first off we might be familiar with
puttan because I too live in Putnam
County um
addressing the eviction part of the last
count of her last part of the question
the governor has think as of today
announced that August 20th all evictions
including residential commercial are
stayed so she shouldn't fear to start
pulling out all park warnings and
personal items out of the store cuz no
one can come and Vic to you no judge is
going to give a court order no Marshalls
gonna come and lock your doors what
they're gonna do in August 20th we don't
know what they're gonna try to give
possibly grants and loans to landlords
to try to subsidize the back rents that
can't be reconciled after so many months
of not being able to pay towards the
workers comp me for I'm sorry towards
the UM the unemployment issue she needs
to keep going onto the website she has
to try to apply there's no one she's
gonna be able to reach on the phone
there are several other sites that she
might be able to go through to New York
gov to see if she's if there's some kind
of paperwork and I seen that she might
have to upload but she's gonna have to
just keep going through that website
towards the stimulus part the IRS gov
does have an actual page to see where
her stimulus check is just get my
payment she needs to click on that it'll
tell her if there's anything outstanding
possibly they don't have a bank account
for her which will delay if she didn't
file her 2000
tax returns that will delayed she'll be
in the next wave not in the first wave
on this many factors but she needs to go
to irs.gov get my payment click on it
and put in her social security date of
birth her address and she should come up
they should be a site giving her
direction after that what to do for
stimulus check unemployment she needs to
continue going on that site we're trying
to get on the phone all day we said
there's 33 to 36 million people on
unemployment right now that numbers
going off by today so that's going to be
a quite a feat but they will get to you
and the good news is they will hold your
place in line so whenever she first
applied she'll be able to get checks in
retrospect however that's not gonna help
but today
all right thanks Luigi Felicia a
question for you from Rhonda Schwarz
Rhonda so Felicia small business owners
who are now eligible to get relief have
told us that they're concerned the rules
for using this money is so draconian
they are worried they're gonna be in
more trouble when they use the money
what have you been hearing from from
your clients about this
Rhonda that's a really important
question for people because these loans
are getting funded as we speak
these PPP loans do have certain
requirements attached to them in terms
of how they need to be used
so the basic requirement is that they're
supposed to be used towards payroll and
that is a requirement that at least 75%
of these loan proceeds are used towards
the payment of payroll expenses and that
could be any cash payroll expenses which
could include not just cash payments
directly to your employees but it could
also include other benefits so as long
as small businesses are using these
loans in accordance with these
requirements they should be okay in the
long run in order to apply for the next
step which is the loan forgiveness so
these loans have attached to them an
important feature that if they are used
correctly and the 75% does go towards
using the proceeds for payroll then
these small businesses can apply for
100% loan forgiveness so that they don't
have to pay
alone at all which is a huge benefit to
small businesses who have been really
hurt financially by closures and so
forth so as long as they can certify
that they've used the proceeds properly
and they'll probably have to provide
documentation to that effect then these
businesses should be okay and I know
that every day we're seeing more and
more guidelines coming down from the SBA
who administers these loans in terms of
how the loan forgiveness is going to be
calculated so businesses really need to
educate themselves and be informed of
the latest guidances in terms of how
they should be spending the money that
they're receiving all right and in fact
the Washington Post
Felisha and Luigi reported in the last
few hours that the Small Business
Administration in terms of its emergency
emergency disaster loan program has just
knocked down the cap from 2 million
Mac's to 150,000 they're just too many
people applying and not enough money to
go around
so Luigi let me follow up with you with
33 million and more unemployed is there
a bottomless pit for unemployment
compensation or is that money gonna run
out too Luigi there's no bottomless pit
for anything
eventually that money will run out I
believe that's part of the reason why
Governor Cuomo is always asking for a
federal government to start bailing out
the states obviously there's these funds
aren't little as we can't just the
states aren't printing their own money
that's through the federal government at
some point they will it will run out and
then the numbers aren't coming down to
continuing to go up and what's quite
concerning with the last regulations
that they employ put in place now saying
that if you can't find work simply for
the reason of the coronavirus in some
way shape or form but I mean a lot of
people possibly haven't worked in a year
or two and that were just jumping on
that bandwagon you're getting on the
point where otherwise they wouldn't have
so that's also overwhelming the system
and I'm worried about how we're gonna be
able to weed that out when we can barely
get the number of claims registered so
are those people permitted to apply for
unemployment even though they haven't
been working for months or years
well the lacs regulations aren't really
specific they say if you're able and
willing to work now and cannot find work
but any reason related to the
coronavirus whether a family member
tested positive used to take care of
them you went out looking for you scared
to travel because of the corona virus
there's a whole list of them ready
general that anyone could fall into that
easily you can click on saying yes I'm
willing to work and yes I'm not going to
travel some scared because of the corona
virus
therefore you technically would be
eligible for unemployment and with the
vast number of people applying whose
there's no one getting on the phone like
they used to do weeding people out that
haven't worked in years or the employer
said no no we fried them for course no
one's checking these things they can't
even get these things signed up in time
now lots of rules to negotiate and
navigate at this time all right well
coming up more of your questions about
cover 19 in the law and the media's
winners and losers the editor in chief
of media will be here to tell us who he
thinks is doing well see if you agree
you're watching the law and crime trial
Network
[Music]
in a way she's almost a younger more
vibrant version of Shanaya as soon as he
met Nicole Kessinger Chris wanted out
she that he would always shoot her that
tells you everything you need to know
about Chris wife that he didn't know
what it felt like love someone
Chris's solution was to pop murder she
had proof something else was going on
continuing now with our special report
and Rhonda Schwartz let's talk for a
moment about the so-called
essential workers those Americans who
are modern-day heroes braving the risks
of going out in the public including the
people who have been reporters and
photographers are out there every day
trying to give us an idea of what's
going on that's right Brian and you know
at a time when we need our local news
more than ever before journalists all
around the country at a time when
newspapers are under siege are putting
on their mass and their gloves and going
out to take the photographs and do the
interviews to bring us the stories that
help bring us all together and I think
we're proud to be part of the profession
I'm proud of all our friends and
colleagues that are out there on the
front lines indeed in fact this week
when the Columbia University announced
the winners of the Pulitzer Prizes the
administrator Dana Kennedy made a
special point of acknowledging those
journalists on the front lines during
the covert 19 pandemic
despite relentless assaults on objective
truth coordinated efforts to undermine
our nation's Free Press and persistent
economic headwinds journalists continue
to pursue and deliver essential facts
and truths to keep us safe and to
protect our democracy they are risking
and far too often losing their lives at
a time when their words their images and
their revelations are more necessary to
our democracy than ever so let's talk
about the essential workers now with our
two fine lawyers of Felicia Ennis and
Luigi Izu let me start with you Felicia
for people who are so-called essential
workers required to be out there what
protections do they have especially with
some Republicans in Congress talking
about putting a cap or a limit on
liability for employers yeah so Brian I
mean there's a lot of precautions that
we want our frontline workers to take in
the workplace but obviously it's a
two-way street right so we want to make
sure that not only are they taking the
appropriate precautions but that these
measures are being important
and their safety is being ensured by
their employers so there is a
responsibility on both sides and that's
really what we're seeing now more and
more as other non-essential businesses
are open opening is what are some of not
just the common-sense approaches that
can be taken in terms of social
distancing and assessing you know
business operations in order to reduce
transmission and protect workers in the
workplace but what could you do
personally for yourself to really ensure
that you're going to protect yourself
when you're you're going out there
including on the front lines so
obviously wearing the gloves and the
face mask is very important but you're
also constantly assessing situations and
trying to avoid overcrowded areas you're
trying to really make sure that whatever
circumstance you find yourself in that
people are still engaging in social
distancing and that you're reminding
people that you know your boat your your
all in this together
and that really for this ever for for us
to ever regain confidence again and
really get out there and start reopening
up America we need to see that these
precautionary measures that are there
for really
not just our safety but for the safety
of all of us are not just written on a
piece of paper but are really being
implemented and enforced by employers in
the workplace by state and local
governments and that's really the way
forward all right Luigi a question for
you sent in by one of our viewers
another owner of the hair salon who's
got a question for you let's take a look
hello my name is what they Abdallah and
I own oasis hair salon in rockville
maryland my question is about the order
that came down from Governor Hogan last
Monday where it indicated that as a hair
salon you can go in and do an essential
employees hair with a letter indicating
that they need their hair done for their
work
otherwise we're going to be fine to have
to find so it's quite confusing because
what essential worker is it that we can
do and what must the letter say
so Luigi what do you say to that that's
a complicated question now that you're
how to even answer that well I mean
first of all I mean I'm not in that
state but if the government is issuing a
rule stating that you can open but the
the client needs a letter stating it's
for employment
you better believe you better have that
letter I don't know what you have to go
so deep into it I don't I don't think
they would say you would have to give a
reason why the employers saying that
employee needs the haircut that's a
whole nother issue as long as she's
keeping track and people coming in and
they're saying for work she needs it
which I'm sure there's plenty of places
that you can't going to work with
uncontrollable hair and people working
certain factories or chemical places or
even I mean they even school I mean
everyone's on skype now so I don't know
but she'd better make sure she has that
letter that's definitely because if the
fines that I'm hearing I know in New
York City some people getting fined up
to $10,000 I know I heard of a homeowner
they had someone painting at home and
they've gotten cooked they got caught
paint their home during this time and
they find the homeowner $10,000 as well
as the company that came in that painted
the house so you definitely want to make
sure you're complying whatever
regulations of our state definitely make
sure you're getting that letter and keep
keep track of it keep them all right
it's a strange world certainly is
felicia a question for you from Rhonda
Schwarz Rhonda so we're using this term
essential worker all the time now has it
become a legal definition how do you
know you're an essential worker is there
is there actually like a legal
definition of who is well certainly that
could be state by state so I know for
example when Governor Cuomo put New York
state on pause Dara was a list of
essential workers that his office
published and to the extent that your
industry or business was not on this
list there was an application process
that you can actually apply to be
considered
an essential worker assuming that you
can demonstrate to the government why
your your particular business needed to
be open but yes to answer your question
around it it depends on what
jurisdiction you're in but essential
workers are defined Luigi we've talked
before about essential workers should
there be or is there some program that
would give them a kind of hazardous duty
pay or a special bonus for working
through this pandemic and serving the
country so well well there should be at
this time I'm not aware of any I believe
the Congress is probably working on the
next stimulus probably provides
something like that obviously these
people have went well and beyond the
call of duty they are putting their
lives on the line every day I'm sure
their families emotionally every time
they come home I worry what's going on
what are they carrying back
there definitely should be something out
there right now I'm not aware of
anything but I'm hoping that Congress in
the next stimulus package put something
together and makes it retroactive
because doing it now and then just carry
them forward and by the time it kicks in
really this thing should go back since
the time it started all right and
felicia final question for you our
lawyer is considered essential workers
not in New York State but I do
understand in some other states they are
considered essential workers if they are
servicing defined essential businesses
so I guess you may be you know a lawyer
for an airline you could be considered
essential in that regard but otherwise
we're working from home like the rest of
those who are able to and we understand
that when the state starts to reopen we
will be in you know one of the first
phases to reopen along with some other
service professional services but as of
now I'm not defined as essential all
right well Felicia Ana's your sensitive
our good program from the Warshaw boston
law group and from Luigi ezel from the
Bourbon Law Group thank you both so much
for being here coming up and we continue
the
is winners and losers the
editor-in-chief of midian is here live
to talk to us about who's doing well and
who's not see if you do agree you're
watching the long crime trial network in
a way she's almost a younger more
vibrant version of Shannon as soon as he
met Nicole Kessinger Chris wanted out
she that he would always shoot her that
tells you everything you need to know
about Chris Watts that he didn't know
what it felt like
loved someone Chris's solution was to
pop murder she had proof something else
was going on
back now with our weekly feature with
Aiden McLaughlin is the editor-in-chief
of media I part of the Abrams law group
as is the law and crime trial of Network
and Aiden every week winners and losers
and quite a few to choose from this week
oh yeah we've got it we've got a couple
starting off with mika brzezinski
Tabitha BC host right let's take a look
at what she had to do with her interview
with a former Vice President Biden about
allegations against him you have said in
the past that if a woman goes under the
lights and talks about something like
this we have to consider that the
essence of this is real
is the essence of what she is saying is
real why do you think she's doing this
I'm not gonna question her motive I'm
not going to get into that at all I
don't know why she's saying this but mr.
vice president as it pertained to dr.
Ford everyone wanted that high-level
Democrat said she should be believed
that they believed it happened
you said if someone like dr. Ford were
to come out the essence of what she is
saying has to be believed has to be real
why is it real for dr. Ford but not for
Tara Reid are women to be believed are
women to be believed unless it pertains
to you so Aidan those were tough
questions that why you chose her as a
winner
yeah exactly so a lot of people thought
that when Biden first announced that he
was going to be addressing the
allegations of taular read when he
selected morning Joe that it would be a
sort of soft ground for him to you know
basically address the allegations under
like questioning from the host because
previously morning Joe has been a sort
of home turf ground for him before but
mika brzezinski interviewed Biden on
Friday and was pretty relentless in her
questioning she particularly honed in on
the contradiction between Joe Biden's
comments about Brett Kavanaugh and the
allegations against the Supreme Court
justice and his now defense against the
tar Reid allegation you recall back when
Cavanaugh was going through the
confirmation process Biden was
one of the many Democrats who came out
and said that women should be believed
and quote was in specifically that the
essence of what she's saying should be
taken to be true now he now says that
clarifies that what he meant by that was
that it was to be taken seriously and
that women for far too long were sort of
dismissed out of hand without actually
listening to their stories so he I think
managed to handle the questions quite
well but Mika Brzezinski definitely gets
the wind from us for just asking them in
a really tough and relentless black and
Aidan it was interesting to me that her
co-host and husband Joe stayed back let
her do the heavy lifting yeah and I you
know I think that made sense Mika
Brzezinski has done a lot of commentary
on this sort of stuff before she was a
pretty prominent voice about the me2
movement for MSNBC when when that was in
and it throws so I think it made sense
to have one interrogator of Joe Biden
and she did a formidable job you know
joe scarborough has had his own
commentary about the situation on
Morning Joe and when Biden not on the
air
so we certainly get to hear his voice
enough and you know Mika Brzezinski she
got praise from across the aisle Fox
News post like Howard Kurtz were
praising her for her interrogation of
Biden so I think she did a really good
job you also picked a loser this week
and Lara Trump let's take a look at what
she had to say and let's talk about that
here's Larry Trump well I would think if
you were being accused of something and
you were totally innocent you would go
to any lengths possible judge to try and
clear your name including allowing
people to open up files like that and
make sure you turned over every single
leaf to prove your innocence
and so Aidan why did you choose her as a
loser right so here's the thing it's
perfectly valid to hold Joe Biden to a
certain standard when it comes to the
allegations of Tara Reid she has put her
name on the record she you know has
spoken up publicly about him and there's
a certain degree of corroboration about
her claims about what she says divided
did her when you talk about
bad state attack against Joe Biden I
think people like Lara Trump who is a
surrogate for President Donald Trump who
dismissed the many allegations against
Trump saying that Joe Biden should do
everything that he can including handing
over documents if he is innocent that
certainly comes off as ironic and a bad
faith argument because Trump did nothing
of the sort and his many surrogates
spent a lot of time especially during
the 2016 election hearing his accusers
instead of actually trying to do the
work to respect that they were saying
and rebut the allegation so you know
it's a double standard that large Trump
and many of President Donald Trump
surrogates are applying to Joe Biden and
they did not apply to the president
right now you picked a winner or later
in the week in Sean Hannity at Fox News
let's listen to what he had to say and
then explain why you saw him as a winner
here's Sean Hannity everyone has the
right to protest protect themselves and
try to get the country open this with
the militia look here and these long
guns no show of force is dangerous that
puts our police at risk and by the way
your message will never be heard whoever
you people are no one should be
attempting to intimidate officials with
a show of force and god forbid something
that happens then they're gonna go after
all of us law-abiding Second Amendment
people so that was a surprise comment by
Sean Hannity at least that surprised me
yeah it was a quite a surprising comment
and you know we might be lowering the
bar a bit here for Sean Hannity but it
was the thing it was an image of a bunch
of armed protesters waving Trump flags
and Sean Hannity might be the most loyal
person on cable news to President Donald
Trump and also worth pointing out that
sean hannity is a concealed carry gun
Toder in the state of New York so here
he is saying that you know Trump
supporters who are storming these state
capitals and demanding that the the
country reopen and protesting no
governor Gretchen Whitmer of michigan
lockdown orders he's saying that they
should be doing it without these weapons
because it's intimidation and they could
result in some serious problems for you
know local law
horsemen so you know him pushing back on
these protests is only a good thing
and you know it comes despite him
talking out against Trump supporters and
you know no doubt many people in his own
audience so we thought that was worthy
of a win and that's why he he was our
winner for I think Tuesday right and
certainly there that many times and he's
been one of your losers or his comments
here consistent with his broad view of
the world or you think he's trying to
clean up his act as it were you know I'm
fairly surprised because Sean Hannity
doesn't spend a lot of time trying to
clean up his act he it's not really the
way he thinks
you know he's ardently supportive of
President Donald Trump whether or not
you know Donald Trump is getting a ton
of criticism or is being praised you
know Sean Hannity you can bet on he's
saying that Donald Trump's doing the
right thing
so this was surprising and a little bit
out of turn and it certainly conflicts
with some of the things that Sean
Hannity has been saying he certainly
been highly critical of governor's like
Gretchen Whitmer and other Democratic
governors who have had fairly strict
lockdown measures so while he's
criticizing those lockdown measures and
saying that the protests themselves are
good he's he's also saying that it's
incredibly dangerous to have those
protests be heavily armed which is
something I think we can all get behind
and Sean Hannity actually got praised by
the hosts of the view for expressing
that disapproval of the protesters which
is also a rare agreement between those
two the view and Fox News primetime hug
I'll say that is a rare one you picked
as a loser last week or this this week
and alack who was essentially the
chairman of NBC News MSNBC why was he a
loser
sure so this is a sort of really
interesting industry shake up MSNBC and
NBC and CNN CNBC are sort of separate
entities under NBC Universal and Jeff
shale the new CEO of NBC Universal
implemented his first shake-up as CEO he
got named a couple months ago and that
involved the ouster of Andy lack was
reportedly planning on retiring after
the election that got moved up he's now
retiring at the end of the month and he
is going to be replaced at NBC by Cesar
Conde who
a lesser-known figure in the
nbc/universal universe now auntie lack
is obviously the loser here because he's
being ousted prematurely also on a raft
of bad press there's been a lot of
criticism of how he handled Ronan Farrow
is reporting on Harvey Weinstein when it
was at NBC before it went to the New
Yorker your call
so he you know has been criticized
there's a lot of antagonism against
Danny lack at the network so you know he
hasn't left on the best of terms also
you know his deputy no Oppenheim who was
often pitched as the would-be successor
did not get the job so he's you know
stuck still at MSNBC and that's also
considered a slight sandy lack so you
know both him and his successor kind of
got the snub this week whereas Cesar
Conde had a pretty stellar week he's now
running NBC News MSNBC and CNBC for the
first time those are all three under the
same person and he's gonna be reporting
to Jeff shell and does it seem like time
is short for no Oppenheim at NBC News
he's still the president there but he
didn't get the big job yeah you know
there was some speculation in a Daily
Beast report that came out this week
that his days might be numbered at MSNBC
I wouldn't read too much into that he's
still running the network and you know
there may be some rumbles from people
staffers at the network that are not too
fond of his leadership and his tightness
the lack but I don't think there's any
sign that he's going to be ousted
anytime soon this seems like a pretty
big shake-up from the CEO oh and I'd be
surprised if there's more ripple effect
all right so the next winner mark Shaw
is now named the he's back at BuzzFeed
why is he a winner why are they a winner
cuz they're laying off lots of people
they are laying off lots of people now
I'll point out that we made Mark show
stood the the winner here not BuzzFeed
news in general because you know
BuzzFeed is going through quite a tough
time the Jonah Peretti to CEO Oh
announced that they're going to be
furloughs due to a steep decline in ad
revenue during the corona virus pandemic
but just looking at the editor-in-chief
of BuzzFeed nude which is news which Ben
Smith built into this serious news
operation with
ton of departments and some serious you
know breaking news chops Ben Smith left
to join the New York Times a couple
months ago to be the media critic critic
for the opinion pages and he left behind
a gap it posed to be nude they didn't
have an editor-in-chief now marks Jeff's
tapped to replace him now he was a
professor of journalism he also had a
serious run at proposed and other
websites and he's a consummate
professional a veteran journalist so I
think it's good news for BuzzFeed and
and certainly a win for the veteran
journalist indeed so we've got about 30
seconds here you picked the White House
dress corps as losers because they
didn't they didn't really confront Kelly
and Conway sure now I think this was a
contentious pick I sort of disagreed
with it but Caleb how one of our editors
went forward with it as a loser of the
day they the press corps didn't ask
Kelly Anne Conway about the pretty
brutal attacks the president Donald
Trump lobbed against her husband he
calls him moon face and said that he was
deranged now two hours later the press
corps had a chance to interview Kelly on
Conway and they barely asked they didn't
even ask her about that which seems like
an odd thing to miss and a real you know
interesting story so there was some
criticism there and and we made them
loser of the day they but if they step
it up later this week all right well a
McLaughlin is always great to have you
on the program
fascinating we'll see what our viewers
think about their winners and losers
thanks again Aidan for being here and
thanks to all you for watching and our
guests today luigi is oh and Felicia
Ennis as well as Ken Diaz I'm Brian Ross
we're back here again next week thanks
to all of you for watching and to our
staff for making it happen
[Music]
you